pleased to have the health secretary
with us this morning hello to you busy
day for you thanks for taking the time
to join us this morning tell us about
your plans to improve access to gps well
first i want to thank gps for the
phenomenal work that they've done
especially during the pandemic but of
course everything they continue to do
and we want to support them to do what
they do best which is to see patients
and to see more patients properly and in
a way that the the patient chooses and
that's what this gp access package is
about that we're now seeing today so it
includes action on multiple fronts to
achieve here just that and you know for
example three of the major measures
inside this package is an extra 250
million pound of winter access fund that
will help increase capacity there's uh
also measures by the uk health security
agency and changes to the social
distancing guidance and then also an
expansion of what's called the community
pharmacy scheme and taken together with
all the other measures this will help
gps to see more people face to face and
more properly should everyone who wants
a face-to-face appointment be able to
have one yeah i think patience i believe
in choice yeah so i i think that's what
patients want to see and the vast
majority of gps uh i talk to they they
say look if you can help us to increase
capacity if you can provide support
that's also what we want to do so i
think patients you should have a choice
and if those if there are some that will
absolutely choose that they prefer
remote or online versus face-to-face and
that absolutely can be right for them
but there should be a choice
um
they feel as though they're under
pressure though don't they feel like
they're being battered by the government
at the moment and they're doing
everything that they possibly can i
think gps are working incredibly hard
and especially over the last couple of
years i mean could there have been a
more testing time for anyone working in
healthcare it's hard to have imagined
that and and i think they have what
they've done especially around the
vaccination program for example has been
phenomenal but at the same time we we've
also seen an increase in the waiting
lists for the nhs more generally we've
seen people stay away from the nhs
including their gps for understandable
reasons uh during the pandemic and so we
do need to increase capacity and there
are many people that will you they want
to be seen in a certain way and i think
it's right that we support gps deliver
that yeah but gps are seeing people more
face to face now than they ever have
been aren't they
uh and i think the from what i've seen
the latest numbers that are published by
the nhs before the pandemic i think it
was roughly around 80 percent of
consultations were face-to-face at the
moment it's around 60 percent and uh and
in general just looking at some figures
so i don't know if you recognize these
in the week beginning 16th of august gps
provided 5.6 million appointments and
gave 374 000 covered jobs at jobs
forgive me 2019 for the equivalent week
5.3 million appointments and no jabs and
there are 1900 fewer gps over that time
so they're doing more work now than
they've ever done before well you uh
maybe the stats you relay is total
appointments rather than broken down
between sort of remote and face-to-face
but it's true certainly gps are seeing
more people including vaccinations
they've been an important part of our
vaccination program
especially for elderly people and going
to care homes in in many cases and
that's been really vital uh support in
terms of gp numbers which you just
touched on look we do have a shortage of
gps in this country and the the
government has recognized that over the
last two years we've actually seen an
increase in the full-time equivalent
number of gps of something like i think
200. so we have seen an increase but i
want to see a lot more
fewer gps over that period of time over
the last two years there's been an
increase um depending on how far back
you go you can have difficulty
cameron was promising us every week at
the dispatch box there'd be 5 000 more
gps were there well i look i want to see
more gps and it will take time to get
more gps into the system this year i was
six years ago well this summer this
summer we had the highest number of
students enter medical school uh for gp
trading and that does mean you know
we've got to we're building that
pipeline but look we've been very clear
about this i think that we do need more
clinicians generally throughout the nhs
whether that's in primary care in acute
care and that is something that's
happening nurses you know we're hiring
many more nurses as well
and that support continues and that
continues with record funding into the
nhs you're both over the pandemic and
before that with the long term plan but
today's announcement is about gp access
and it's right that we provide more
support
embracing the technology you don't have
to be face to face quite often i
interview your colleagues down the line
doesn't mean that what they're saying is
any left effect lesson we should
absolutely be making maximum use of
technology throughout the nhs is
something i've talked about very
recently actually how i want to see that
and what we have seen during the
pandemic is that people understand at
that time at the height of the pandemic
you could only be seen remotely everyone
understands that and there will be some
people that think maybe if they've done
that for the first time that suits them
they might have a busy life it might be
a minor illness and that might suit them
and that's that's a decision for them
but what i've also heard is from gps
directly is that we need more support
you need to cut away some of the
bureaucracy we face you need to give us
more funding so that we can perhaps work
overtime and open longer hours and
support us with that and you need to
speak to the ukhsa to see if they will
continue with their review of the nhs
and the infection control guidance and
which which you know which is what's
happened and so we've been listening
we've taken action
and i want to thank again gps for
everything that they're doing they will
continue to have the full support of the
government of the nhs in everything that
they do yeah are you listening though i
mean
um a survey from the bma you know giving
you figures again 50 of doctors
suffering from anxiety depression stress
or burnout
60 high levels of fatigue 30 taking up
additional unpaid hours to try to make
sure they're there for their patients
when they're needed i was speaking to a
gp this morning who said to me ask him
who runs the nhs you or the daily mail
well the nhs is run everyone knows how
the nhs is run through
a professional your serious management
we've just appointed you ceo of the nhs
and its gps that will decide in their
particular surgery how they're going to
run that day-to-day but what they've
also done but but what they what they've
also said is that they need more support
to to see more patients differently
they're born
they're knackered they're depressed
and they feel that you're bashing them
well actually
there are there have actually been over
the last uh a few months i've certainly
noticed while i've been in this job
there have been some horrid cases of
abuse towards health workers to social
care workers to gps uh including that
and i have to say that is totally
unacceptable at any level there's a zero
tolerance as far as i'm concerned about
abuse to anyone
health and social care and what one one
of the reasons that gps have said to me
that they they feel pressured is because
of some of the abuse that they suffer it
might be online abuse it might be
anonymous and one of the things i've
included in this package as well is for
the first time a 5 million pound
security fund so for those gp surgeries
that feel that they want to take extra
measures on security there's support for
that as well and the final thing if i
may mention something else i do want to
do and i can't announce the full details
of it today because i want to work with
gps and the nhs more broadly and get it
right is when i was a home secretary i i
decided i wanted to do something that
became the the police covenant to
provide more long-term support put it
into law for police in that case of
course and i want to do something very
similar for all nhs workers of course
including our fantastic gps and i want
to work with people and get that right
to show
and and also demonstrate and give more
support yeah they don't feel supported
they feel bashed by the government
that's that's my point they don't feel
that you that you've got their back well
this this whole package today is about
support the the funding that we're
putting in the extra 250 million a
quarter of billion pounds of new fresh
funding is something that we've been
asked for and in fact many people from
the feedback i've got already have been
surprised by the size and the of the
financial support that's being provided
but the support we're providing through
working with the pharmacist so that they
can take some of that load off gps and
deal with some of the minor illnesses
the support we're providing and taking
away some of the red tape and this is
all support and it's all about helping
gps so they can do what they love best
which is seeing their patients but you
know you plan to name and shame those
who don't actually reach those targets
that you're going to put in front
whatsoever for that i mean that we what
we are doing is perception is reality
and this is what my this is what a gp
said to me this morning when i told him
that you were coming into the program
these are the points that he wanted me
to put and then that and that gp
obviously i don't know who that is but
entitled of course to their views but
it's also important that we stick to
facts and so what we are doing is uh
providing more data and more
transparency so these are people on the
front line and they don't understand the
facts is that what you're saying well
we've published a document today i don't
know if the the document was published
this morning at around 6am so i don't
know whether the the person that you're
referring to has had the time to read
the entire document which goes into a
number of pages and goes into immense
detail i mean
do you know if that person read the
document first i have no idea well there
you go so uh based on the facts do you
think that that this is based on it
that is going to change all of the um
frustrations of these gps half of whom
are suffering from depression i think
it's going to help because this is about
providing more support
more financial support removing the red
tape that gps have often talked to me
about it's about spreading the workload
for for primary care for example using
the community pharmacy scheme more it's
provide support also there's a there's a
plan in there to provide direct support
to those practices that ask for it that
would like more expert advice and and
the nhs can send in a team and help them
with that and the point i just wanted to
make because you did touch on it it's
about transparency at the moment uh when
you get data at a gp level it's only
available at a regional level not
practiced by practice the nhs now for
well over a year has been
piloting the scheme i think with 60
practices where it's practiced by
practice data and this is important it's
important that patients have this
information because i also want to see a
leveling up of healthcare throughout the
country i've talked a lot about
disparities in healthcare and i think we
do need to understand what the
differences in healthcare provision are
across the country and have the best
data available okay you talked about
transparency there did we ever intend to
stick to the protocol when it
came to the brexit agreement over
northern ireland because of course
you'll know mr cummings has said we
signed the deal never planning to stick
to it and to ditch the bits we didn't
like further down the line we signed
that agreement in good faith i was in
the in the government then in a
different role and i know we signed it
in good faith and uh of course it's been
two years roughly since then and it's
right that we look at how it's working
we don't think it's working well in
practice
we think for example the eu is taking in
an over-legalistic approach and i think
it's right that we talk to our friends
in the eu again and see if any changes
can be made so what they've said is as
you know because i'm sure you've read it
um they're basically budging on 80
of the uh the options for uh amongst
other things sausage wars as it's been
described but one thing they've even
moved a little bit as far as what the
european court of justice is concerned
and whether they will be overseeing
the change in rules is that going to be
enough i i haven't seen the eu document
yet i haven't had any time to study it
it's good that they are engaging with
this discussion i know for example from
the area that i'm responsible for your
medicines healthcare more broadly that
we've had issues with medicine supply in
northern ireland and no one wants to see
issues like that it's not in anyone's
interest whether in northern ireland or
ireland for that matter i think it's
important that these discussions
continue and if sensible changes can be
made that's exactly what we'd want to
see is the european court of justice a
red line for the government
i think we do we there's no
really looking forward there should not
be a role for the european court of
justice in in anywhere any part of the
uk and that includes northern ireland i
think it's a an over-legalistic approach
that the court has so they've got the
sticky fingers anywhere near it we're
not it's not a dream and it's and i
think lord frost has been really clear
about this with the speech that he made
this week and and what he said i think
are the the principal uh arguments and
and one of those issues one of the most
important issues is to end the role of
the ecj in northern ireland and i think
that's one of the the better ways to
make sure that we're also protecting
what was agreed in the good friday
agreement for the benefit of not just
everyone in northern ireland but an
island too the whole island of ireland
yes safety and security in northern
ireland of course but it does sound as
though we're going to reject it from
what you're saying look that's not a
decision uh for me and uh i'm focused on
health matters you've asked me about the
protocol i've shared my views but you're
representing the government this morning
i know it's something that uh lord frost
will look at very carefully and uh if
the government decides to to take a a
different approach then it will be a
collective decision okay just a quick
thought before i let you go i read in
the paper this morning that your mum had
always wanted you to be a doctor
um i'm guessing she might want you to be
a lorry driver at the moment we're in
short supply
well i think the government's addressing
that issue there's a supply of lorry
drivers across the world and i think
there's a shortage of four hundred
thousand roughly in europe and some
seven i don't know why they don't wanna
come here we wanted five thousand twenty
so far i think being a lawyer is a great
job uh by the way and so uh i hope that
you managed to get that in just under
the wire through our lower drivers this
morning i think i i hope that more
people are attracted to that why do you
think they're not
i think it's multiple issues it's got to
we've seen this issue across
europe across actually recently in the
us as well there's a shortage and uh it
and it's i think a lot of it has to do
with the pandemic and the sudden demand
that's been created as the world's in
effect sort of waking up
after the economic shock and it will
take some time to sort this out in terms
of what we've done in the uk to attract
more people into the industry that's
going to help and and i'm sure that you
know this will be something that will be
resolved in the months to come